Hôm chuyện thức buổi tế vào khoảng 30 sáng ngày 20 tức tăng sống theo dưới phương,
một loa buộc nổ mạnh đã sảy ra tại cú bực phía bác và chung tâm thủ đông tên Rang Gui Rang
làm giống chuyện thịn khổ, các ngon tinh kiên nhận sự hiện dịn của máy bay chiến đấu trên không,
và thời điểm sảy ra vụ việc.
Đáng chú ý vô nổ diễn xa chỉ vài dơ, sau khi tổng thống mi đường nân trang công bố một thỏe thận ngu bắn
dựa y seren bẩy ran đã đặt được. Thưa đầu y ran sẽ lập tất chấm rất thức của tấn công,
trong khi y y seren sẽ bất đồng bắn sau mười hay dơ.
Sau hà mi tương dơ, hay bên được kỷ vọng sẽ chính thức tên bố, chấm rất của chiến kéo dài mười hay ngày.
Tuy nhiên, y ran đã đưa ra điều kiện dân, bù trường vậy sao a bác rõ chi trở biệt,
tế ra sẽ chỉ dân có khu tấn công. Nếu y y seren ngu ngừng không cích từ mỗi dự sáng theo dưới ran,
sống hơn 3 tình dựa y sống bế móc thử dân được ông trăm công bố.
Nếu dựa ông hay hà mi tự tự tự sáng, chuyện thông nhận nước y ran tên bố,
lấy ngu ngừng bắn đã đưa thiên lập sau khi ngu ngừng này thực hiện của tấn công bằng tên lửa vào các ngu quân sự của Mỹ tại Qatar.
Bây giờ ngu ngừng lại y seren cũng đau một đời công kích từ y ran sau công bộ ngu ngừng bắn,
con đối seren sắc nhận phát hiện tên lửa phóng tự y ran và đã khi có thể thống phóng đủ lánh chạng.
Một quan chức cáo của nhà chẳng tư lộ rằng y seren cũng đã đồng ý với các thở thuật ngu bắn,
bây giờ kịn y ran phản ngu ngừng của tấn công vào ngu ngại.
Thật thận ngu bắn được chào là cái quả từ nỗ lực trung dân của Qatar sau phóng cho đối dự tổng thống trung,
và quân vâng sẽ trăm mì mình ha mắt an tình.
Chắc khi đó, có thống thống Mỹ trên y vence đã phối hợp với tụ tưởng Qatar,
bây giờ kịt kết khu hệ của Qatar.